[Music]
on this Tuesday night Canada's inflation
rate deflating once fueled the slight
drop food prices though are still Rising
there comes a point where it becomes
frightening and what it could mean for
interest rates
sobering study on drinking alcohol new
recommendations on how much is too much
they were like wow and the evidence of
the risks
a Montreal hospital's emergency why
nearly 100 nurses are threatening to
quit tomorrow
plus saving Ukrainian culture this war
could have serious consequences one
architect's blueprint to protect prized
and Priceless monuments
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is a sliver of Hope tonight for
Canadians burdened by the High Cost of
Living Canada's inflation rate dipped to
its lowest point last month in nearly a
year the Consumer Price Index slowed to
6.3 percent in December that's down from
6.8 percent in November it is in large
part because of a 13 drop in the cost of
gasoline however the price of groceries
is still going up increasing 11 percent
year over year every Canadian is paying
more for food and those who can least
afford it are slipping further into
despair every week food banks the first
line of defense are struggling to meet
the demand in our top story tonight
Heather York's West looks at the reality
of food insecurity in Canada
with two little girls including one with
severe food allergies just keeping
everyone fed has become a major source
of stress we're noticing especially with
algae friendly food unfortunately it
happens to be more expensive
um so it means that we're either having
to try and stretch our meals further
um at times in the past like my husband
and I have you know skipped meals if
it's meant that you know we can feed our
children we've never seen anything like
this in our 40 Years of business with
the rising price of food the Calgary
food bank is currently helping 1 000
individuals and families every day but
it's not enough to keep Pace with demand
as a result many in need are waiting
almost three weeks this is not
sustainable we cannot keep doing this
every month this is a growing problem
it's not about a lack of food it's about
a lack of money to buy food and these
decision makers across the country have
to look at what's going on researchers
out of the University of Toronto
estimate there are currently more than
5.8 million Canadians struggling with
food insecurity in terms of households
that's one in six and while Canada has
Income Support programs they haven't
been enough to turn the tide only Yukon
Alberta Quebec and New Brunswick index
their Income Support programs to keep
Pace with inflation but even then
researchers say these programs don't go
far enough I think there's a needs to be
a real conversation around making these
benefits uh
based on the actual cost of living that
people are facing so that we're actually
talking about programs that enable
people to to get by until then families
like Laura's are left just trying to
cope there comes a point where it
becomes frightening as the price defeat
her family only continues to climb
Beyond reach Heather your ex West Global
News Calgary
another drop in inflation in December
even though it was a small one is a
positive sign what might it mean for the
rest of 2023 in terms of interest rates
and the possibility of sliding into
recession that is what Ann gaviola is
looking into tonight
gas and other commodity prices have come
down on concerns of a slowing global
economy helping to cool inflation to its
lowest point in nearly a year we're
already seeing the success of tighter
monetary policy on retail spending for
instance we're seeing that we're seeing
the impact certainly of higher interest
rates on housing and housing prices
still Canadians paid higher mortgage
interest costs steeper rents food
inflation remains stubbornly High all of
this food for thought for the Bank of
Canada and its quest to tame inflation
the central bank's next interest rate
announcement is January 25th and money
markets expect a quarter percent hike in
2023 is shaping up to be a rather Rocky
year for the Canadian economy a new
report by Financial advisory firm
Deloitte forecasts a recession starting
with negative growth in the first half
of this year even though we're making a
recession call we are saying that it's
going to be relatively mild compared to
historical standards the thinking and
economic downturn will be cushioned by a
strong labor market but we're not immune
to International risks with the U.S our
largest trading partner China the
world's second largest economy just
announced its worst growth rate in
nearly half a century plus the toll of
the energy crisis in Europe overall it's
going to be a relatively challenging
next six to nine months for for many
Canadians but relief is expected toward
the end of 2023 when many economists say
we could see inflation return to levels
closer to 3 percent which is the upper
edge of the bank of Canada's Target and
gaviola Global News Toronto
how much alcohol we can safely consume
is being drastically rethought new
recommended guidelines for Canadians
advise even moderate drinking anything
more than two drinks a week puts your
health at risk the update is from the
Canadian Center on substance use and
addiction which reviewed six thousand
studies on alcohol use it defines a
standard drink as 12 ounces of beer 5
ounces of wine or one and a half ounces
of spirits according to the report
consuming no alcohol has significant
benefits to health and sleep three to
six drinks per week puts you at moderate
risk of developing seven types of cancer
including colon and breast cancer and
more than seven alcoholic drinks a week
puts you in increasingly high risk of
heart disease and stroke Mike droulet on
the new thinking about the risks of
drinking
whether it's at a bar a sporting event
or party alcohol isn't merely prevalent
it's celebrated in society today a
decade ago the medical community put a
number on what moderation looks like no
more than 15 drinks per week for men 10
for women but now after a review of 6
000 medical studies the new recommended
guideline is no more than two drinks we
were also very shocked about how
um how much different and how far we've
come in the science since 2011.
and um you know frankly we're like wow
like how you know how are we going to
get people to drink two drinks a week
how indeed the Canadian Center on
substance use and addiction wants
warning labels placed on bottles
informing consumers of the increased
risk for cancer heart disease and stroke
so after seven drinks the risk is
exponential
to rate than it does at the moderate
level France has had labels on its
bottles since 1991. yet a recent study
found that they were too small and
lacked information in short they were
ineffective
Canada's wine industry has another idea
labels but with more focus on
information than warnings uh 12 or 10 to
alcohol bottle wine is going to happen
obviously a lesser amount of alcohol
than a 15 uh alcohol so uh putting that
on the label and understanding what a
standard breakiness makes total sense to
us now the recommendations are just that
recommendations which help Canada is in
the process of reviewing in the meantime
from a long-term medical point of view
the news isn't all Grim if you've been
drinking really heavily for the last
decade and we're very unaware of these
risks there is the potential the damage
isn't necessarily done it's a dramatic
shift from previous reports well
Canadians listen
Mike drolet Global News Toronto
federal government is appealing a recent
Federal Court ruling that would further
extend the deadline for submitting
claims in a military sexual misconduct
class action settlement this is in stark
contrast to concerns raised by prime
minister Justin Trudeau in 2018 over how
the justice department was arguing these
types of cases
and I've asked the Attorney General to
follow up with the lawyers to make sure
that we argue things that are consistent
with this government's philosophy
obviously what what the lawyers of an
argument does not align with with my
belief or what this government believes
in its latest filing the Department of
Justice argues that a section of the
settlement agreement that allows claims
to be submitted beyond the deadline was
misinterpreted and that the judge made
errors of law the original January 2022
deadline was extended earlier this month
after 12 people sought to join the class
action hundreds of claims are said to
have been submitted since last year's
deadline
emergency room nurses at a major
Montreal Hospital walked off the job
overnight ambulances had to be
redirected and the hospital's ER was
open to only the most urgent cases it is
a conflict that's months in the making
it may have been temporarily cooled down
today by quick action from provincial
officials but as Mike Armstrong reports
the nurses are still threatening to
resign on mass if more of their demands
aren't met
this was the moment nurses walked out
stop in the emergency room at mesone
hospital in Montreal's East ends say
they'd hit the breaking point they'd
eventually go back inside and treated
patients who'd already been admitted but
that was it the evening staff decided to
stay in the in the coffee room and don't
go to work
ER reopened at 8 am but the nurses Union
threatened Mass resignations if its
demands weren't met and said the
overcrowded ER was a toxic work
environment and called for the unit's
manager to be removed and it demanded an
end to forced overtime nurses often show
up for an eight-hour shift and are told
they have to work two shifts back to
back I have a lot of colleagues that
have a family and have kids and I don't
know how they do
to to live like this it's impossible
okay well the pressure tactic forced
immediate action within hours the head
of the regional health board and the
provincial Health Minister were involved
in person the unit manager was moved out
of the ER and an independent outside
person brought in to mediate I just want
to reassure patients that we are taking
that seriously the ER has 62 patients
right now that's barely over capacity
over the last month it's been running on
average at 103 percent it would normally
be considerably higher the issue for the
nurses is Staffing they love doing their
job but it's very tough right now
there's not enough people and there's
way too much mandatory over time now the
waves may be coming from this hospital
but the problem is widespread often
nurses and other staff at other
hospitals are forced to work 16-hour
shifts in some Hospital you can have 15
20 of the staff working as mandatory
overtime which is it's not good the
Health Board hopes to reopen the ER
fully they are redirecting ambulances to
give staff a bit of air critics say
that's not a long-term solution it's
barely a short-term solution Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal
police in India have arrested and
charged two men in the death of a family
of four who died in Manitoba last
January trying to cross the border into
the U.S a mother and father plus their
11 year old daughter and three-year-old
son froze to death in a field while
trying to walk from Canada to the U.S
during a blizzard police told the times
of India the family was reluctant to go
but The Men Who police say acted as
immigration agents told them the stormy
cold weather conditions were ideal
covered across into the U.S undetected
the two men are charged with human
trafficking and criminal conspiracy
police say other suspects are wanted in
Canada and the U.S
a search for unmarred Graves using
ground penetrating radar a former
residential school in Ontario has found
more than 170 anomalies was Nation says
what it calls plausible burials were
found within Cemetery grounds at the
former Saint Mary's Indian residential
school in Kenora a news release from the
nation says with the exception of five
grave markers the remaining are unmarked
by any grave or burial markers the site
has been secured representatives are now
meeting with the federal government to
discuss the path forward
bad news for a lot of people who booked
vacations with sun wing the airline has
canceled nearly all flights out of
Regina for the rest of the winter
because what it calls operational and
business constraints and a release the
airline said the cancellations are
effective February 4th with the
exception of a handful of Departures
passengers can travel from Saskatoon or
Winnipeg instead or get a full refund
Sunwing had already canceled all trips
in and out of Saskatchewan between now
and February 3rd the airline received 7
000 complaints from customers left
stranded or delayed during the holiday
travel season
an American political candidate Behind
Bars coming up the violent crimes he is
accused of committing against his rivals
a disturbing tale of politically
motivated violence is unfolding in the
U.S police in New Mexico say a
republican candidate who lost his
election has been arrested in connection
with a string of shootings targeting his
political Rivals Solomon Pena is alleged
to have paid four men to carry out the
crimes in one case even pulling the
trigger himself Jackson prosco reports
his Fall From Grace began at The Ballot
Box and ended with his arrest by a SWAT
team Solomon Pena was taken into custody
Monday a failed Republican politician
accused of hiring people to shoot at the
homes of local Democrats It is believed
that he is The Mastermind that was
behind this and that was organizing this
the shootings began in December first at
the home of a county commissioner then
three lawmakers homes were hit including
a state senator in that final case
police say Pena joined his Hired Guns
and pulled the trigger himself at least
one of the alleged gunmen is now
cooperating with police the evidence
that we have is not only firearm but
it's also from cell phones and
electronic records surveillance video
and multiple Witnesses inside and
outside of this conspiracy in November
Pena lost his own election to the New
Mexico State Legislature by a landslide
47 percentage points just like his
apparent Idol Donald Trump he refuse to
concede at the time he tweeted now
researching my options prosecutors say
after his loss Pena confronted several
of the lawmakers who later became his
targets he had complaints about his
election he felt it was rigged so he
approached all of these Commissioners
and the Senators at their home with
paperwork claiming that they were there
was fraud Pena also claims to have been
in Washington on January 6 2021 when
Trump's supporters stormed the capital
Albuquerque's mayor believes this was
far more than a case of political sour
grapes this type of radicalism is a
threat to our nation and it has made
its way to our doorstep right here in
Albuquerque New Mexico Pena's alleged
targets have gone from deeply shaken to
relieved even in this tense partisan
environment few would have expected to
see a defeated politician accused of
armed Revenge Jackson prosco Global News
Washington
[Music]
protest ahead Greta tunberg among those
detained by German police
in Germany climate campaigner Greta
tunberg was among a number of activists
detained by police while trying to stop
the expansion of a coal mine
tunberg was carried away by officers in
riot gear and was seen sitting alone in
a large police bus the climate activist
has been supporting a protest over the
demolition of a village in Germany to
allow for the expansion of a huge open
pit Coal Mine activists believe Germany
should not be mining anymore coal and
should instead focus on expanding
renewable energy thousands have
participated in the protest which began
January 10 after having her identity
confirmed tunberg was released
there is a demographic shift happening
in China that country's population has
declined for the first time since 1961.
in the last year China's population has
dropped by 850 000. a decline was
expected but it's happened a decade
sooner than predicted China dropped its
one child policy in 2015 and the
government has been encouraging citizens
to have more children but its birth rate
is at a record low incentives include
tax breaks and lowering the cost of
child care however it hasn't been enough
to offset the rising cost of living
China's government says labor demands
are being met however in order to avoid
an economic crisis some policies such as
pensions will likely need to be adjusted
he has been ostracized by the film
business in much of the world because
he's facing multiple sexual assault
charges but Kevin Spacey was welcomed by
the national museum of Cinema in Italy
last night and given a Lifetime
Achievement Award
[Music]
Spacey thanked the museum at the sold
out event he said he's glad it had the
balls to honor him with the award this
was the highest profile appearance for
Spacey since more than 20 men have come
forward and accused him of sexual
misconduct on Friday he pleaded not
guilty in the UK to seven charges of
sexual assault the trial for those
charges as well as five others begins in
June in London
protecting culture next how are
Ukrainian architect is working to
preserve Ukraine's Heritage in case it's
destroyed by War
[Music]
this inscription has archaeologists in
Norway excited it's believed to be the
world's oldest discovered runestone the
writing is thought to be 2 000 years old
and dates back to the earliest days of
the enigmatic history of runic writing
the flat Square block is sandstone and
it was found during the excavation of a
burial ground ruins are the characters
used in northern Europe from ancient
times until the adoption of the Latin
alphabet well preserving the past isn't
always possible but an architect in
Ukraine has a plan to ensure his
country's most historic and beloved
buildings and monuments aren't all lost
to Russia's aggression UNESCO believes
at least 235 cultural sites have been
damaged since the invasion began last
February now as Redmond Shannon reports
3D technology is being used to save them
from disappearing completely
is one of Eastern Europe's architectural
Jewels its Old Town a UNESCO world
heritage site
the church of Saint John the Baptist
dates back to the year 1250. the city is
close to the Polish border and has so
far escaped the worst of Russia's
Invasion despite ongoing airstrikes
against infrastructure but local
architect yulian chaplinski notes that
one missile strike could change that
we're now standing in a passage that was
destroyed by a German bomb in 1939. last
year we saw Rockets hit key from other
cities and I realized this war could
have serious consequences ukrainians
have been using sandbags to protect
monuments but that is only practical for
smaller structures and even then would
be useless against a direct hit
so chaplinsky started to raise funds so
that Annie levive building or monument
that does get destroyed could be rebuilt
as precisely as possible
enter 3D scanning technology this team
is working on the Dominican Church in
levive
in total we now have 40 monuments
scanned using a laser scanner
photometric technology a drone and
photographs the results of the save
Ukrainian Heritage project look like
this digital models covering every nook
of History inside and out it complements
other initiatives like this one where
smartphone users can scan smaller
historic objects
it is difficult for me to say what is
most valuable everything is valuable in
leviv it was not for nothing that leviv
was included in the UNESCO world
heritage list the team wants to expand
its work Beyond Live But ultimately it
hopes none of these models will ever be
needed Redmond Shannon Global News
London
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is Winnipeg's sturgeon Creek a place
close to my heart and where I grew up
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]